Did you ever find out what the blood work pattern could indicate on Tony's line?
Yeah, it was, I was correct when I
Bencheted to you. It's, it's most likely a bacterial infection, but the high monocytes also could indicate
what I suggested to was Epstein-Barr as well. But most likely bacteria, most likely
it's H. Pylori. That would indicate the granulocytes with the bacteria. It could have secondary
Epstein-Barr, that's resurfacing. So, Epstein-Barr is a virus that could live in the
injured nerve ganglia forever, and you, you could never kill it. So, a lot of viruses you could
never totally kill, because there's argument whether they're actually most likely to
live in organisms. So, Epstein-Barr is one of those that could be dormant in your system,
but then when you're compromised, anyway, that could come out. And that's what I'm suspecting,
because that's what I mentioned. We talked about getting the liquid berberine
from Santa process, but you said they don't make that anymore. Their liquid golden seal is extremely
expensive. You do have access to the core berberine by energetics. That has barberry,
coptus, oregano, grape, golden seal, and lung balm. That would be a good substitute. So, yes,
dosa says 30 drops twice a day. Yeah, or you could just do, you know, try just 10 drops at every
feeding, not right now, through the, and I think that product is fairly, it's not very viscous. So,
I don't think you'll have a problem with it clogging up the feeding tube at all. So, I would get this,
I would try this one. There isn't, you look, there's not really any other liquid berberines
on the market, but I would give this one a try. The company is a good company.
If you can't, somehow you can't get it, we can't order that. So, let us know, let beg it know,
and I can order that. We don't have it on the store, but I can order that.